this is it baby three weeks we got the
presidential election
you know what could go wrong dude we
both look like cops
yeah we do it's just a we're we're a bad
two dudes
to be walking around any of these cities
if [ __ ] goes down
this is making me like him more
it's the only other place i could live
maybe
the great state of florida oh this is
sick i mean dan usually do airbnbs this
time we got a room
so you know if one of us [ __ ] somebody
we have to wait outside but
we just got a few more weeks a couple of
big podcasts are about to happen
i'm doing a podcast with joe rogan and
alex jones next week
and an election special so i'm sure no
one will get mad about that
do you need anything no we're perfect
right now okay fluffy bobblehead
fluffy uh sold out a club in like 20
minutes
uh by just tweeting it out in san
antonio and then the next night i
performed for like 12 people
and then i realized that like man i
gotta step my [ __ ] game up
this great show tonight dan's friends
came out his best friend came out
and uh dance fans coming out to the show
tomorrow that'll be good dan had a great
set
i come on i did very well and uh
you know we're very excited now i gotta
do an hour podcast because people on the
patreon already probably be like hey
[ __ ] you we pay for this
we just did a podcast we just filmed the
uh we just recorded
i'm like delirious we did two shows i
did two hours
dan did 20 minutes on each show which is
gr which is impressive we see about four
and a half minutes of material
and then i just did a podcast we did a
50-minute podcast what we got to do we
got a
and and i think it was decent you know
and obviously but maybe not the greatest
thing i've recorded but
this is what we got to do one patreon
podcast a week
and one filmed podcast a week for
youtube
and then you know stand up stand up most
days
what is what is your shirt saying
i just i want to pay black people to
kill you
i want to go on reddit my name is tim
miller thank you guys so much
[Applause]
not tim dillon is it yeah dylan come
here dude
yeah give it to me a little bit how are
you i love your [ __ ]
thank you brother billy powers thank you
what's up
is the steakhouse brand
you're the steakhouse tip dylan yeah
so hold on hold on please don't film
this when i was in the it was an ocean
and it was raining it was like one of
the most beautiful things i was in the
ocean it was raining
it's one of the most beautiful things
and um there was a couple that had just
gotten engaged
and i'm in my underwear and i'm i'm just
in the ocean and i'm going like this
it's like the shawshank redemption i'm
doing that scene
from shawshank redemption i'm in the
background of all of their photos
and i'm just screaming it dan it's the
shawshank redemption
and this is the happiest moment in their
life they literally turned around and
looked at me
and i'm just shirt off like this is the
scene from the shawshank redemption
and um it's moments like that that make
this country beautiful
yo what up what's up we're in the car or
the wood west palm beach
i said rush limb by an email he's dying
of cancer i want to interview him
i've been listening to him since i'm 12
years old i don't think he's going to
respond
but i'd love to talk to him even off-air
you ever listen to rush a little bit
a little bit mostly through you he's
alive
he lie we do this all day the lying has
to end
listen man whether you love her hate
rush he's one of the biggest
broadcasters
that's ever lived i'd love to [ __ ]
sit down and talk to him
blow cigarette smoke in his face and you
have uh
you have some other pretty big
interviews coming up i have a big
podcast coming up with rogan
and alex jones it's going to be
happening on
monday it is now friday
it's a little wild because i'm sitting
next to alex who i've been listening to
forever but who is the most
volatile person on the planet also the
funniest
so i'm trying to be funny next to the
funniest dude
no one's funnier than him he's not
trying but he's funny
and uh we're a week out from the most
contentious election in american history
so in terms of podcasts it'll be the
biggest thing i think i've ever done
so it is a little nerve-wracking being
like dude what the [ __ ] what's this
gonna look like are people gonna be like
tim dill is a monster for doing it
who cares whatever but it's been making
me a little anxious
you know dan has probably noticed that
to a degree
yes have you noticed
have you noticed that i've been like
kind of
tense there's
the armor is strong but there's a little
bit of tension there's a little bit of
a little bit of anxiety rightfully so
just give i started this tour in
non-smoker and i was doing keto
this morning we had pancakes and
cigarettes for breakfast i'm just a
little
tense you want to say [ __ ] that's funny
and that you mean
right now because neither one of these
candidates is good
and i don't want to give anybody the
idea that either one of them is good
and alex is all in for trump
and i'm telling people make your own
decision i don't really give a [ __ ] what
you do
there's negatives to either one of these
guys getting elected
and there's probably positives to either
one of these guys getting elected
who the [ __ ] wants to hear that though
so i better just be [ __ ] funny
okay yeah this is this is
exactly why i used to do coco
two little beds in there this is cocaine
this
is you say i want to buy an eight ball
of cocaine i want to cut it up
i want to sniff it and then i want to
peek out of the blinds
and look at the parked cars on the
street and wonder which ones of them are
undercover cops and i did that for 10
years of my life
and it's not that bad
you know the one thing about this state
the [ __ ] humidity
yeah we they started asking us what we
want green rooms and we eat these
protein bars it tastes like
cookies and cream that tastes like
chocolate candy bars so now we're just
gonna have that and then hopefully we
got some yogurts i requested five
yogurts they're [ __ ] yogurts it's
actually
it's greek yogurt but it's it's the [ __ ]
alex just text me he's like if you're in
austin early come have dinner with me
let's do dinner and drinks
so we may be doing that so
hey what's up everybody my voice is
going and uh i
am really trying to do the best i can
here we got
we got halls uh for the voice we've got
[ __ ]
room temperature water for the voice we
have marburg lights
but we are in palm beach right now we're
trying to do a quick video outside of
jeffrey epstein's match
jeff just lane it's going to be a little
tough
people have told us that the cops will
come right away um there might be like
palm beach private security there is
[ __ ] construction
going on in the house next to his or
you know it's the a joint cia massage
front
you know venture where it's just a bunch
of agents sitting in the truck eating
sandwiches i don't know
you didn't get into the epstein dock you
watched an episode i watched an episode
i was like this is a little much
you know you're never like a big you're
never like a big fan of my podcast
i i listened to your podcast i was never
a big fan of anybody's podcast though
okay
yeah but you don't really you don't what
i like about you is you don't really
look at the darkness underneath
no not not too much maybe a little bit
but i don't really poke that much
i think before just do you think that's
why we we we were a good like match
i think so yeah i think so i like kind
of like
i don't say basic [ __ ] [ __ ] but maybe
more basic [ __ ] [ __ ] than you do
like i enjoy brunch i think brunch is
fun
yeah i like it is that is that is that
is that funny what do you mean lacking
brunch
no they could be actually yes if you
the fact that you hate it so much and i
like it is funny okay
yeah do you know why i hate it um
well here's why i hate brunch it's
confused
breakfast ninety percent of all
breakfast you eat are haras
they're a father and his uh divorced kid
a divorce father and his
daughter at a diner it's a bunch of old
guys in a mcdonald's drinking coffee
that are veterans
you know that serve the country that
doesn't care about them um
it's a substitute teacher eating an
energy bar on her way to work
it's a guy that just got out of rehab
trying to get a call center
job stuffing an energy drink down his
throat 90 percent of breakfast you
and it was all in your garage and we
used to watch alex jones every night and
we watch joe rogan every night yeah and
we watch
other people that we won't name it or to
be unnamed
and we would sit in his dark vortexes
and the only things that would glow were
the lights of these little shitty mac
minis
and you would just see plumes of
cigarette smoke and then the lights
of this dystopian reality that was
becoming like
actual reality and we were always saying
to ourselves like what when will this
spill over
when does this go out in the streets
because all we would watch is
anger and rage would be very funny but
we went when does this
spill out into the streets and now we
know
right it was march two thousand now you
know it's march 2012
yeah i mean i used to fall asleep
to our shows every night
yeah and you would watch it late into
the night yeah and i wrote a script
about you yeah just talk about that
i went crazy for like a month i worked
like maybe like
300 hours on a script where tim is
essentially like playing the story of
alex jones
and i had this idea for like months i
was like i'm gonna write this whole
script
and then like lay it before 10 like a
voila
yeah like and then i spent like
so much time on it and i handed it to
you
and you read one page of it and you're
like this is so
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you're like we could get sued of course
we can't do this
what were you thinking it was like
you're loosely playing out
it's like amy page you used like it was
like 100 pages of full script like a
feature
and i took it i like threw it i just put
it on a coffee table and i was like well
i think you should read it i think it's
pretty damn good
and you're like no i'm sure it's you're
the first script you ever wrote i'm
showing oscars and i was like
yeah you don't need much you don't need
anything
then i need a schizophrenic ding
and somebody who will deal with
schizophrenic that's kind of all you
need
and an internet connection
i'm excited the jurgen experience
tim [ __ ] yeah i'm just a kid in
a candy store
thank you thank you for making this
dream come true
have you smoked crackers no free based
cocaine which is basically
yeah it's close how close is it not not
as close as where i ever went made shady
deals in the ukraine
get him some apple juice for the
transhumanism discussion please listen i
brought you the documents joe
we have the documents this is why people
get banned
from the internet this this these kind
of conversations
we better ban it right now let's not ban
it
i'm just not i'm throwing that out if we
don't break the last record we're going
down what's the last record no we don't
have to break
records no tim dillon you rant why get
ready
give us your latest comedy
it's maybe one of the best podcast
episodes ever
amazing amazing i think people see alex
as a human being which they should
uh i tried to be funny when i could and
we talked about some really interesting
[ __ ] and that's what a podcast should be
like that's literally what a podcast
should be it should be just a
no-holds-barred conversation that nobody
really
like there's no there's no limits
there's no rules to what you can [ __ ]
talk about and
everybody has you know their own
experience or
whatever and i think it was really
[ __ ] good
entry is coming in from spinach we've
orlando some aqua and potatoes
we're gonna go ahead and cut up this
pork chop right here that's right for
six hours of pecan but it's really
fantastic
does everything look okay it's beautiful
perfect i think
purchasing high weaponry anonymously
is my right so if i think that's
probably the biggest threat
like if i were to go buy an ak-47 and
somebody said hey what's your name
it's going up i just put it on instagram
and now i'm putting it on twitter
and alex jones
so [ __ ] you to all the teachers who said
i wouldn't amount to anything and all of
them worked at
uh all the work in newton connecticut
what a horrible joke
spotify is having a meltdown right now
[Laughter]
yeah the frieza's lane show is amazing
spotify employees in shambles
massive walkout spot
[Music]
going around the desert trying to get
supplies for sketch and the
supplies we needed like syringes they
think we're drug addicts
put it that way we're like for a sketch
we need uh syringes
and uh you know a spoon a lighter
for first sketch you know let's say my
wife was
dead and i wanted to get rid of her body
what chemicals would i need for a sketch
for youtube we're about to walk in a
walmart this is more dangerous than
licking the floor of the covered wing in
a hospital
no it's the if your health food thin
mint
it's the fat bomb bar no it's
it's the health food aisle dummy
mint fat cups
the kids are going to love vaccines
every holiday they're going to want a
new one
where's my easter vaccine mommy and then
the easter bunny shows up and gives it
to them
um is there a funny line if you're
pulling back you're pulling different
needles out of there like that one's for
malaria what's that doing in there
so look at this it's a bowl of candy
is it or is it the end of coven
that's right kids they're cutting
capacity in a lot of these clubs so
i have decided that we should basically
go back when we can do full rooms or
half full at least
which is what we've been doing we're
doing a lot of full rooms three quarters
full
i don't want to do a hundred people in a
room that sees 500 that's not how comedy
works but we're going down to do the
election night podcast with rogan
um and then we're gonna we're gonna be
down in austin for that one night for
the
most volatile election in american
history they're boarding up all these
cities
they are you know walmart is stopping um
you know selling
guns and ammunition i mean it is
people think it's truly going to be
really bad which means it might not be
bad
it's very interesting when people really
prepare and over prepare
it might mean that actually it's not
going to be that bad or
it's going to be horrible downtown
downtown yeah lovely
seems fun
guard's around the capitol the national
guard is in the cabin yeah it's crap
what a day what a day what a year
what a year is right how do you think
what do you think covent did to comedy
[Laughter]
because we planned this out it's [ __ ]
terrible it's the worst thing to happen
for comedy ever yeah
it hit the brakes on stand-up comedy for
[ __ ] eight months
yeah it's awful i i think the good news
is there's a lot of people that really
shouldn't have been in comedy that are
gonna quit
you know and the bad news is it's really
hard to see comedy
if you're a fan and for comics to
perform it's really difficult
for comments that didn't have a podcast
it was a real wake-up call they're
[ __ ] they're [ __ ]
that was that's one of the more
interesting things that comics realized
like oh
i can't count on hollywood to pay my
bills because all hollywood productions
shut down too
and it's sort of uh it highlighted the
value
of being an independent podcaster or a
youtuber
just having your own content that you
put out where people can
just see you without any [ __ ] you
know you don't
you don't have to have an executive
telling you what to do or someone hiring
you you just do it
yeah but i have it at now is like uh
at 2 56. there it is podcast studio
this is it folks this is my room this is
we've said we had a podcast studio in
the [ __ ]
in my room here and uh
that's where i scream and yell i
screaming y'all at this bed all right
i'll leave you guys alone
thank you thank you dan thanks bye
everybody
bye guys thank you